when they had traveled I know not how
many days the Tartar baron fell sick so
that he could not ride and being very
ill and unable to proceed further he
halted at a certain city so the two
brothers judged it best that they should
leave him behind and proceeded to carry
out their commission and as he was well
content that they should do so they
continued their journey and I can assure
you that whithersoever they went they
were honorably provided with whatever
they stood in need of or chose to
command and this was owing to that
tablet of authority from the Lord which
they carried with them so they traveled
on and on until they arrived at layoffs
in her mania a journey which occupied
them I assure you for three years it
took them so long because they could not
always proceed being stopped sometimes
by snow or by heavy rains falling or by
great torrents which they found in an
impassable state they departed from
Laius and came to Accra arriving there
in the month of April in the year of
Christ 12 69
and then they learned that the Pope was
dead and when they found that the Pope
was dead they went to a certain wise
churchmen who was Leggett for the whole
kingdom of Egypt and a man of great
authority by name of Theobald
of PA chenza and told him of the mission
on which they were come when the
legate's heard their story he was
greatly surprised and deemed the thing
to be of great honor and advantage for
the whole of Christendom so his answer
to the two Ambassador brothers was this
gentleman you see that the Pope is dead
wherefore ye must needs have patience
until a new pope be made and then shall
ye be able to execute your charge seeing
well enough that what the legate's said
was just they observed but while the
Pope is a making we may as well go to
Venice and visit our households so they
departed from Accra and went to
Negroponte
and from negroponte they continued their
journey to Venice on their arrival there
Messer Nicholas found that his wife was
dead and that she had left behind her a
son of 15 years of age whose name was
Marco
and tis of him that this book tells the
two brothers abode at Venice a couple of
years tarrying until a pope should be
made when the two brothers had tarried
as long as I have told you and saw that
never a Pope was made they said that
their return to the great card must be
put off no longer so they set out from
Venice taking mark along with them and
went straight back to Accra where they
found the Leggett of whom we have spoken
they had a good deal of discourse with
him concerning the matter and asked his
permission to go to Jerusalem to get
some oil from the lamp on the Sepulcher
to carry with them to the great car as
he had enjoined the leg at giving them
leave they went from Accra to Jerusalem
and got some of the oil and then returns
to Accra and went to the leggett and
said to him as we see no sign of a Pope
being made we desire to return to the
great calm but we have already tarried
long and there has been more than enough
delay to which the leggett replied since
it is your wish to go back I am well
content wherefore he caused letters to
be written for delivery to the great car
bearing testimony that the two brothers
had come in all good faith to accomplish
his charge but that as there was no Pope
they had been unable to do so
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]